[Musique]
août
alors c'est parti bonjour à tous j'ai
fait une petite diapos de présentation
alors voilà ça c'est moi il ya mon mail
en bas si jamais vous voulez m'écrire
n'hésitez pas j'aime beaucoup la lecture
donc là je vais vous faire une petite un
petit retour d'expérience sur ma chaîne
youtube que j'ai lancée en 2015 je crois
et qui se bat par hugues géologie depuis
2010 est donc c'est pas si vieux aussi g
même si ça peut être vue comme très
vieux à l'échelle de
youtube mais ces récents à l'échelle des
temps géologiques voilà il fallait que
je commence par cette petite blague donc
je commence par parler de moi parce que
c'est ce que je fais de mieux alors tout
a commencé
quand je suis né dans une petite
banlieue parisienne alors dès le début
mes parents ont vu qu'il y avait un truc
qui n'allait pas chez moi donc c'est pas
ça
par match et l'épée madiot bref donc je
vais vous parler de ma chaîne youtube
voilà que didier a présenté tout à
l'heure il ya des vidéos qui parle de
géologie tout ça mais on y reviendra
tout à l'heure avec des guest de qualité
comme suffit ici
donc je vais commencer par expliquer mon
parcours donc comme je le disais dès le
début mes parents ont dû qu'il y avait
quelque chose de pas tout à fait normal
chez moi non c'est pas ça je suis
remonté trop loin donc tout a commencé
quand j'étais des études de géologie et
c'est là en licence donc que je me suis
mise à aix marseille que je me suis mise
à prendre des photos de caillou avec
avec des objets de vendre des marteaux
parfois des marteaux avec l'étiquette
encore dessus parce que j'écouterais
flemmarde parfois des doigts à des
endroits qui m'indique absolument rien
genre là c'est ce ne sera rien pour
l'échelle n'est pas grave
donc je me suis dit un jour que ce
n'était pas fait pour moi la géologie
particulièrement après avoir vu un
concert de de richy hallyday qui est le
sosie officiel de johnny hallyday et que
j'ai vu vraiment concert à palavas les
flots et là c'était vraiment une
révélation pour moi et du jour au
lendemain je me suis dit je ne peux pas
être géologue je veux être biologique et
donc j'ai fait des études de bio à jésus
fait un master en d'écologie
particulièrement à montpellier et à
l'occasion de ce masters j'ai pu faire
un stage à au canada au canada ou que
j'ai pu manger des crabes des neiges
éviter les stalactites et faire une
hypothermie c'était très fun et donc
c'est là je me suis dit que la biologie
ce n'était pas pour moi et donc du coup
j'ai fait plutôt à un master en
journalisme scientifique ce que je me
suis dit que c'était bien le journalisme
scientifique et donc c'est un master key
à paris diderot dans lequel jean sagnes
maintenant et
alors là je n'ai pas compris il s'est
mis à se passer plein de choses je ne
saurais pas encore tout expliquer encore
aujourd'hui mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que maintenant je suis foutu buzz ça on
peut le dire j'ai travaillé pendant deux
ans comme tu le disais tout à l'heure à
sciences et avenir en tant que
vidéaste d'un journaliste vitesse
généraliste donc en fait j'accompagnais
des journalistes sur le terrain où
j'allais tout seul pour deux reportages
des interviews des trucs comme ça et
puis je les monte après j'ai eu à
l'occasion de ces deux ans
enfin l'honneur l'insigne honneur
d'élever un blob
qui s'appelait dylan voilà le nom n'est
pas de moi mais je m'en suis occupé près
fièrement avant qu'il demeure et voilà
et donc après ça je me suis lancé à
plein temps sur ma chaîne youtube chaîne
que j'avais commencé pendant mon master
de journalisme scientifique donc à
l'époque c'était plus une
expérimentation en fait donc je faisais
un peu des interviews un peu touché ciel
faire un pont un peu sérieux puisque je
me suis dit que ça me servir un peu de
vitrine professionnelle et puis quand
j'étais à sciences et avenir je me suis
dit bon bah j'ai plus vraiment besoin de
victimes professionnelles parce que je
publie par ailleurs donc je vais faire
vraiment ce qui m'amuse et puis des amis
m'ont dit pourquoi pourquoi tu ferais
pas des blagues toi tu serais pas plus
naturel dans cette vidéo est donc ça
c'est le mot clé de
ce moment de file de cette conférence
c'est l'authenticité et à mon avis c'est
ce qui marche le mieux sur youtube c'est
d'être authentique et donc c'est là où
j'ai commencé à faire n'importe quoi
enfin à faire des blagues sur youtube la
première vidéo de géologie qui a marché
sur ma chaîne c'était la première vidéo
de jeu et la première vidéo un peu drôle
c'est celle où jeu léché des cailloux et
j'expliquais en fait pourquoi les
géologues et des cailloux enfin qu'est
ce que ça peut enfin ce que ce peut
indiquer comme comme caractéristique sur
les différentes roches par exemple et
cette vidéo a plutôt bien marché j'ai eu
des très bons retours du public dessus
donc je me suis dis bah je vais
continuer dans cette lancée à la fois
parce que l'humour c'est rigolo et ça
plaît et à la fois parce que la géologie
c'est un créneau qui était pas tellement
crise je crois sur youtube à ce moment
là et encore aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
grand-monde dessus et donc je me suis
dit que c'était l'occasion un peu de
montrer une autre facette de la géologie
et montrer que ça peut être science est
intéressante est vaste et rigolote aussi
pour un peu casser cette image de
voiliers bien l'image que peut avoir la
géologie de la pop culture je reviens
pas là dessus et je pense qu'il y en a
beaucoup qui doivent se battre au
quotidien pour lutter contre ça surtout
s'il ya des médiateurs dans la salle
donc
[Musique]
voilà donc ça c'est la fameuse vidéo je
lèche des cailloux je donne vraiment de
ma personne dans cette vidéo il ya aussi
deux minutes une ou deux minutes je sais
plus à la fin de la vidéo où c'est
uniquement moi qui mange un rocher
suchard entier en plan séquence donc
voilà c'est vraiment axé sur le contenu
scientifique avant tout non en fait
c'était surtout au départ c'était pas
mal de sciences un peu d'humour et puis
plus ça va plus il ya du mauvais cinéma
c'est un équilibre à trouver
là donc c'est un autre exemple de vidéo
alors je sais pas si c'est la peine mais
si c'est possible de montrer un petit un
petit goût de la vidéo
si si si tu reviens sur ok alors je vais
essayer de l'avancer je ne sais pas si
ça va marcher à suspense donc dire et si
vous voyez la vidéo qui les démarque
c'est juste pour avoir un peu le ton que
j'emploie et les différentes mises en
scène ce genre de choses
hop est ce que vous voyez
l'onglet chrome qui s'est ouvert
non
non alors
d'être partagé oui faut changer le
partage peut-être oui
il faut que je trouve comment rouvrir
c'est aussi un lien comment nourrir
correctement y'a rien effectivement
c'est vrai marché l'eau
le lien marche les sam envoie vers une
autre page qui est du coup n'est plus
partagés d'accord c'est compliqué est-ce
que voilà comme ça ça devrait marcher
qu'est ce que vous voyez
pas être anglais google
youtube
un nom
[Musique]
entre temps
alors je recommence
est-ce que là ça marche
sept points
m oui c'est bon oui c'est bon ça devrait
marcher donc je lance pour quelques
tiendrait pas longtemps oui ça va
alors c'est parti
par contre c'est sans son
on n'entend pas le soin à mars
là vous n'entendez pas non
vous avez du talent je perdais pas
peut-être donc c'était plutôt véronique
que valentine
samson
ah oui j'avais
vraiment cru bon bah du coup c'est pas
grave mais je peux vous montrer des
images à défaut donc là c'était une
vidéo où j'explique les trois grandes
familles de roche comme vous voyez
absolument pas au titre d'ailleurs c'est
une de mes particularités c'est qu'en
général les titres ne sont absolument
pas transparent et très plus tacler
comme des dons qui incite à cliquer mais
de la mauvaise façon pour les mauvaises
raisons et donc ça commence bien et en
même temps tout du long de l'explication
je fais comme si j'étais au restaurant
et je mange des choses seulement parce
que sinon c'est pas drôle
donc là il ya le moment où j'ai mangé
mabouka baisse et évidemment ça a mal
fini et puis après je mange des choses
diverses et variées enfin voilà à chaque
fois ça finit mal
et il comprit le café pour finir je vous
passe les détails
surtout avant de manger du coup hop je
vais essayer de relancer un partage
d'écran
sur la bonne image
là normalement vous avez accès un média
peau
et c'est reparti donc voilà c'est pour
donner une idée un peu de ce que je fais
j'essaye de mettre un peu l'accent sur
la mise en scène et un humour de
préférence de mauvais goût et absurde
comme vous voyez là par exemple sur la
droite de l'image c'était le schéma du
cycle des roches donc les cycles enfin
les roches magmatiques qui deviennent
métamorphiques sédimentaires tout ça
avec le magma au milieu du coup j'en ai
fait un truc absolument une mine donc ça
va à l'encontre de la de la didactique
mais j'ai trouvé ça drôle et du coup je
les mets dedans
je me tire un peu une balle dans qu'est
donc la recette de mes vidéos c'est
avant tout des cailloux et de l'humour
et des silences gênés mes objectifs sont
plusieurs c'est avant tout le
divertissement
ça je trouve ça important de se poser si
jamais vous voulez monter une chaîne
youtube de se poser avant et de brannens
réfléchir à l'objectif qu'on envisage
pour notre chaîne donc ça peut être du
divertissement ça peut être de
l'enseignement mais c'est bien d'avoir
la tête claire au début pour faire un
contenu un peu cohérent et sabots ou pas
l'idée c'était de dédiaboliser à la fois
le front national et la géologie est
aussi de montrer la diversité de la
géologie parce que très régulièrement
quand j'en discute avec des amis même
même la semaine dernière une disent
toujours c'est audacieux d'avoir fait
une chaîne sur la géologie est ce que tu
vas avoir à cette vidéo à faire comme si
le sujet vous pouvez s'épuiser en trois
vidéos et donc c'est là où ils se
rendent pas compte dans tous les sous
domaines et toutes les disciplines
différentes qu'il ya au sein de la
géologie et donc je pense que c'est là
qu'on a comme un autre rôle à jouer pour
montrer tout ça mais bon je pense que je
prêche un public
mon public cible voilà c'est alizé non
pas du tout c'est en fait quand j'écris
mes vidéos je pense à
je pense à ali non plus je pense à
pardon
je pense à ma petite cousine qui est pré
ados et donc j'essaye de faire en sorte
que mon contenu scientifique soit
compréhensible par elle après les
blagues c'est pas du tout on remarque
elle elle peut la regarder elle peut
rigoler à ça mais c'est vrai que les
blagues s'adresse plutôt à un public
plus averti que ça mais en tout cas le
niveau de difficulté scientifique
j'essaye que ce soit compréhensible par
des par des collégiens lycéens quoi
entre les deux après peut-être que je
suis pas bonne là dedans du tout mais
c'est le mec que je sais mon public
effectif et c'est là ça va peut-être
devenir intéressant pour vous c'est
qu'on va parler se tape mon public
affectif dans les fesses et les retours
que j'ai c'est surtout des parents qui
regardent les vidéos avec leur en prend
quand les vidéos sont pas trop trash
évidemment
parce que les enfants aiment bien
justement le bon coup de quand je me
mets quand je me verse la bouillabaisse
dessus ce genre de choses ça plaît
toujours et moi qui suis une grande en
france ça me plaît beaucoup de le faire
dès que c'est parfait
c'est et mon public c'est aussi les
étudiants surtout ceux qui travaillent
assis en tailleur sur des tables et qui
ont l'air beaucoup trop peureux et aussi
les jeunes actifs
mais pas que il ya aussi des gens plus
plus âgé parce que en fait quand on
regarde les cobras alors déjà on peut
voir aux images précédentes que j'ai un
peu menti parce que en fait il ya très
peu de femmes par rapport aux hommes sur
ma chaîne depuis le depuis sa création
il ya à peu près quatre ou cinq fois
plus d'hommes que de femmes je suis pas
bonnes stats mais
vous faites le calcul c'est un peu
terrible après il faut savoir que c'est
un peu la norme dans la vulgarisation
scientifique j'ai pu comparer les stats
avec ceux de quelques amis mais bon ça
dépend c'est quand même pas très haut
pour moi
dire la proportion de femmes est quand
même pas très haut août je saurais pas
expliquer ça peut-être qu'on peut en
discuter ensemble après
après pour continuer dans l'east ap donc
là je dis spectateurs je vous disais
c'était surtout des étudiants des jeunes
actifs tout ça ça fait vraiment une
courbe en cloche
alors après encore une fois il ya
peut-être des billets dans ses stats
c'est à dire que ceux qui ont 13 17 ans
est ce qu'ils indiquent à google quand
ils s'inscrivent qu'ils ont 13 17 ans
sachant que ça peut leur limiter l'accès
à certains contenus
je sais pas peut-être qu'un biais de ce
côté là mais
et puis aussi est le fait des gens qui
regardent à plusieurs autour de
barcelone
bon il ya tous aidé à prendre en compte
mais dans les faits c'est surtout les 25
34 ans qui sont sur ma chaîne qui est
relativement classique aussi vis-à-vis
des autres youtube a aussi en
vulgarisation scientifique
donc voilà pop
côté origine géographique c'est surtout
des français de souche il ya un petit
peu des francophones au sens stricte
hanche
mais c'est quand même surtout des
français ne serait ce que parce que je
sous titre pas mais vidéo en langue
étrangère donc que c'est limite de fait
l'accès aux autres
aussi bonne que ce soit la bouillabaisse
et ce qui est intéressant à voir c'est
aussi sur quels termes terminale sont
gardés mais vidéo et ça je pense que
c'est pareil un peu pour tous les goûts
les youtube heures
c'est là où on voit que la première
place c'est sur mobile et après sur
l'ordinateur et ça peut aussi être
visionnés sur des grands écrans de télé
et donc ça c'est important à savoir
quand on est un créateur parce que ça
permet d'adapter la façon dont une fait
nos vidéos parce que il faut que si on
écrit du texte par exemple ou si on
montre des choses à l'écran il faut que
ce soit visible sur un tout petit écran
de téléphone et que ce soit pas
complètement dégueulasse ci s'est
projeté sur un téléviseur grand écran
donc c'est là où il faut s'adapter aussi
si on met des sous titres nous mêmes il
faut voir la taille de police ce genre
de choses ça sur youtube un
dispositif de sous titres intégrés donc
normalement ça se présentent peut être
voilà et un truc ça c'est plus pour moi
puisque je pense pas que ça vous
intéresse trop mais le nombre de gens
qui regardent les vidéos en fait il ya
deux tiers des gens qui regardent mes
vidéos et qui ne sont pas abonnés à mach
aller
ça c'est pas terrible pour moi j'ai pas
comparer cette donnée là avec d'autres
vidéaste je sais pas si c'est bien ou
pas mais ça veut quand même dire qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens qui sont pas abonnés
à ma chaîne et qui regarde mes vidéos
qu'ils n'ont pas le réflexe de s'abonner
c'est un peu bizarre mais d'un autre
côté ça veut dire aussi que j'ai un bon
trafic qui vient de l'extérieur bref
c'est je rentre dans le détail on s'en
fout un peu mais
donc les retours du public que j'ai sur
mes vidéos c'est que elles les font
mourir de rire que je suis vraiment
extrêmement drôle et aussi que ça leur
montre un autre regard de faim ça leur
offre un nouveau regard sur la géologie
j'en ai plusieurs qui m'ont dit que
avance y regarder enfin s'il voyait
passer un article de presse qui parle de
géologie ou ce genre de choses il aurait
absolument jamais regardé et maintenant
depuis qu'ils ont commencé à regarder
mes vidéos ils se disent ah bon bah si
jamais je croise un article parle de ça
et bah je vais peut-être lire le titre
pour moi c'est déjà beaucoup donc je
suis content c'est déjà un petit un
petit changement
voilà après
le fait est que ça a l'air de plaire
puisque ma groupe d'abonnés voilà ça
monte à chaque fois que j'ai sorti une
vidéo
une vidéo qui a bien marché d'où
l'importance de sortir des vidéos
ça pour vous je reviens en vie de façon
mon processus d'écriture même si je lui
ai rien d'original là dedans mais en
gros je choisis mon sujet d'abord donc
j'ai une liste de sujets ou sinon ça
peut être des trucs qu'il vienne au
cours de la conversation avec soit des
amis niçois la famille soit des gens du
domaine ou pas
donc par exemple je prends l'exemple
d'une vidéo c'est peut-être en avant
dernière je sais plus j'ai fait une
vidéo sur la structure interne de la
terre
donc pour ça j'ai fait des recherches
bibliographiques
sur des avec des sources primaires donc
la plupart du temps en fait ce que
j'utilise c'est des gros bouquin
académique écrit en anglais par des
chercheurs qui ont des chercheurs donc
ça c'est vraiment ma bible c'est toute
la ville et jane et donc pendant les
pendant les recherches bibliographiques
je prends des notes et si j'ai des idées
de blagues qui me viennent des jeux de
mots ou des trucs comme ça je les nôtres
immédiatement dès que j'ai des idées un
peu un peu folle je les note avant de
les oublier
et puis aussi j'ai des idées de mise en
scène aussi ses moments de de les écrire
donc ça c'est j'ai un baume brouillon et
après ce dob brouillon je vais leur
écrire proprement en mettant vraiment
donc
vraiment l' approche journalistique
c'est à dire que je vais avoir un angle
et puis à partir de septembre qui est
mon message essentiel je vais essayer de
dents dérivés un
plan détaillé et ce plan détaillé je
vais remplir avec les différentes notes
que j'ai prise dans mes dans mes
documents biographiques et aussi je vais
essayer de soigner la croche et la chute
particulièrement surtout la croche mais
on va revenir après on va voir pourquoi
exactement
voilà et donc au moment de la rédaction
encore une fois là je rajoute une couche
de blagues une couche de mise en scène
voilà plus permettre mieux c'est il y en
a jamais trop j'ai l'impression
donc ça c'est un exemple de script comme
j'ai pu écrire alors c'est une ancienne
version de ce script qui a pas mal
évolué
donc là c'est la croche dont je vous
parlais la cena croche que j'ai changé
parce que finalement elle ne
s'appliquait pas là mais donc là en
l'occurrence c'était bonjour à tous sauf
à mes voisins du dessus à ceux qui font
la pub de north bay pn et ceux qui
disent du coup du coup cette vidéo est
sponsorisé par marie pm donc je n'ai pas
utilisé cette intro parce que la vidéo
en question n'étaient pas sponsorisé par
l'enveloppé m mais croyez bien que je
vais réussir les cette intro dans une
autre vidéo ce qui est pratique c'est
que c'est tellement pas spécifiques que
je peux la passer d'une vidéo à l'autre
c'est complètement l'inversé de ce qu'on
apprend en école de journalisme ou
vraiment un truc spécifique normalement
lasser c'est très générale c'est juste
pour la blague donc j'ai commencé par
une petite une petite histoire une
petite anecdote tout ça c'est ça marche
toujours
tout de base de storytelling comme on
est maman de scénarisation
et puis voilà donc je raconte des choses
j'ai des titres si j'ai des mises en
scène les explique là aussi si j'ai des
indications pour le montage ou pour le
tournage je les indique aussi d'une
certaine manière et puis ce document là
après j'en fait mouche une fois qu'il
est prêt je le transforme en chez
compteur pour pouvoir le lire
directement au tournage et donc ce que
je vous disais de soigner la croche le
début c'est particulièrement important
parce qu'en fait on a globalement dix
secondes pour capter l'attention du
lecteur dans une vidéo quand l'attention
du spectateur et là c'est une courbe qui
est relativement typique vous voyez que
là donc ça c'est le nombre de gens qui
restent sur la vidéo à partir de 100 %
là en fonction de la longueur de la
vidéo donc à quand la vidéo commence il
ya plus de 100 % ça je ne saurais pas
l'expliquer c'est peut-être des gens qui
sont revenus au début de la vidéo est
très vite afssa chic et sa chute ça veut
dire que là il ya plein de gens qui sont
partis plein de gens plein de gens et
donc là ça doit être les
les 30 premières secondes je pense
qu'ils sont qui sont surlignés donc au
bout de 30 secondes il ya déjà
plus que 75 % des spectateurs
qui avait au début donc là un quart des
gens qui sont déjà barré donc c'est pour
ça qu'il faut être vraiment très
comment dire qu'entre est très brutal
quand on balance l'information ou la
blague au début il faut vraiment capté
l'attention par tous les moyens de
possibles au début surtout pour une
vidéo de jeu
voilà donc ça c'est un exemple
voilà ça aussi c'est terrible en moyenne
les gens regardent moins de la moitié de
la vidéo en général j'ai des chiffres
qui sont autour de la moitié mais c'est
terrible de dire ça quand même
pour pas s'arrêter là dessus c'est
déprimant donc une fois que j'ai
mon script bien écrit je le faire relire
par un expert du domaine que je vais
contacter et aussi par un novice
donc l'expert ses pouvoirs le fonds
scientifique et le novice c pour voir si
c'est compréhensible et aussi s'il
rigoler aux blagues enfin si mais effets
de style de rythme et tout ça peuvent
fonctionner ou pas et donc comme ça je
revois le script en fonction
ça peut aider aussi le lire à voix haute
moi c'est ce que je fais beaucoup de
lire le street à voix haute pour voir si
tout marchait bien camping quand on va
tourner la vidéo ça permet de faire
gagner un temps cible parce que si au
tournage on voit qu'il ya une phrase qui
fait les trois kilomètres et du coup
c'est pas possible à lire c'est très
compliqué d'aller modifier le fichier
prompteur tout ça alors que si on le
fait en amont ça fait gagner un temps
fou tournage et le temps c'est de
l'argent non mais du coup c'est
important et un autre ce que je faisais
aussi qui peut aider ces deux de
s'enregistrer au dictaphone tout
simplement sur son téléphone par exemple
de s'enregistrer en train de lire son
script et après de le réécouter est
comme ça ça permet vraiment de prendre
du recul sur ce qu'on a écrit de se
rendre compte qu'il ya des éléments qui
manquent pour comprendre le raisonnement
si au contraire il ya des moments où tu
fais chier enfin voilà c'est ça permet
vraiment prendre du recul et c'est assez
testé à prouver je passe pas mal de
temps aussi autour des accessoires de
mes vidéos alors ça peut être une
vieille pipe que j'ai récupéré dans le
grenier qui appartenait à mon arrière
grand père et du coup on a remis un peu
en forme pour pouvoir m'en servir
jusqu'au début de la vidéo ça dure
exactement 3 secondes je fais semblant
de fumer la pipe et après je commence à
faire la vidéo ou là par exemple c'est
ma maman qui m'a fabriqué à un collier
en mini saucisson
je ne la remercierai jamais assez pour
ça et ce qui est drôle c'est qu'en fait
la plupart des gens qui regardent la
vidéo ne s'en rendent pas compte et ils
sont obligés d'aller regarder dans les
commentaires et c'est là où il se rendre
compte que d'autres l'ont remarqué et du
coup on vous voir la vidéo et du coup
ils vous regardez la vidéo et c'est bon
pour mes stats excellent c'est mon plan
machiavélique pour la petite histoire ne
fait pas ça parce que le collier de
saucisson sous le sous la lumière des
leds pendant un tournage de deux trois
heures j'ai pu jeter toutes mes fringues
après
bref donc dans certaines dans certains
cas aussi là pour la bouillabaisse en
l'occurrence j'ai même un storyboard
parce qu'en fait c'était hyper compliqué
il y avait plusieurs caméras qui
tournent en même temps et surtout je
n'avais pas le droit à l'erreur parce
que je peux pas refaire un plan du début
alors que je suis à la fin du repas et
j'en ai déjà plein de t-shirts donc là
vraiment j'avais j'avais droit qu'à une
prise à chaque pas quasiment
et du coup il fallait que je fasse à un
découpage technique
carey est aussi un storyboard et donc
voilà vous pouvez admirer mes talents de
dessinatrice au passage surtout là
dedans et donc ça ça va être vraiment
beaucoup au tournage avec des petites
indications aussi si j'ai besoin
d'accessoire je le mets donc là j'avais
besoin d'un feuilletés au fromage par
exemple là j'avais besoin d'une wii
c'est un bout que j'ai coupé j'étais
censé le faire terrassé par une
météorite pendant mon copain enfin bref
donc ça aussi il ya des bouts qui sont
coupées au tournage d'une classe je me
fais percer un seau d'eau dessus quand
je suis par terre donc ça aussi il
fallait tourner tout à la fin il fallait
que je me change parce que j'étais un
autre personnage feindrait c'était
compliqué mais du coup je vous encourage
à faire un storyboard que vous faites un
truc un peu compliqué ça fait gagner
beaucoup de temps et c'est vous allez
plus sereinement au tournage et y
voilà
ça aussi donc pour le pour le script en
question ce que j'aime bien faire c'est
d'indiquer donc la séduit phase calme le
décor c'est dans mon décor studio de
base la liste des accessoires qui me
servent comme ça je sais que quand je
filme cette partie là il faut que j'ai
ça sous la main c'est particulièrement
utile quand je parle de plein de
cailloux différent je peux savoir que
dans tel parti il va falloir que j'ai
tel cailloux sous la main tel autre tel
parti bref vous avez
heureusement que c'est un métier de
parler du public alors après il ya le
tournage donc ça c'était pas à pas le
même ton âge pardon je couds et puis le
montage
donc le montage qui me prend pas mal de
temps et en même temps je fais un petit
teasing sur les réseaux sociaux en
partageant des images si j'ai des
captures de l'écran rigolotes ou des
trucs comme ça des bouts de vidéos que
je peux sortir et que je mets sur
twitter la plupart du temps de n'est pas
que ça peut être falloir aussi par
exemple eh ben ça ça aide aussi à faire
patienter le public à faire un peu
monter la sauce et puis et puis moi ça
me rapporte
de l'enthousiasmé enfin j'ai plus envie
de continuer à monter la vidéo quand je
vois qu'il ya des bons retours dessus
des
niveaux de temps faire une vidéo ça me
prend entre 100 et 150 heures à peu près
le montage ça fait une cinquantaine
d'heures de base la rédaction par une
cinquantaine d'heures donc en général ça
peut être un peu plus quand je dirais
d'action ça peut être ses rédactions et
recherche vidéo mais quand je me plonge
dans mes énormes bouquin voilà pour
reprendre toutes les bases de telle ou
telle science évidemment une fois pas
mal de temps et puis le tourner le
montage évidemment je fais plein de
bêtises qui c'est je peux passer une
demi-journée à faire des effets spéciaux
qui vont se voir sur deux secondes ou
même une seconde des fois et moi ça
m'amuse beaucoup mais effectivement ça
prend du temps
et voilà et c'est toujours des effets
spéciaux complètement débile sinon c'est
pas drôle
voilà et donc après le montage je publie
la vidéo quand je suis contente de moi
et je suis tout ça sur les réseaux
sociaux évidemment et donc la vidéo dont
je vous parlais sur la structure interne
de la terre elle a fini comme ça donc
avec ce titre là qui n'a rien à voir
avec la vidéo en question pain avec le
sujet
avec unique c'est vraiment un titre
complètement plus ta clique avec des
émaux j avec écrit en majuscules sauf le
et et c'est un peu ma marque de fabrique
ce moment en fait au début c'était juste
pour le gac mais ça marche tellement
bien parce que il ya plein de gens qui
sont un peu maniaque et qui du coup
m'écrivant commentaire le e majuscule
c'est il faut faire un tel code halte
144 je sais très bien mais du coup en
plus ça génère des commentaires donc
c'est bon pour mon référencement sur
youtube donc je continue à faire ça
parce que il continue à faire ça de leur
côté donc ça va ça m'amuse beaucoup donc
je pense que dans toutes mes dernières
vidéos il ya est minuscule à un endroit
et il ya toujours des commentaires
dessus et voilà et le fait de mettre un
petit commentaire en entre parenthèses
derrière ça aussi c'est la mode du que
j'essaye un peu de surfer sur les modes
appareils miniatures très très coloré
avec ma tête dessus enfin voila je
j'expérimente encore j'ai pas j'ai pas
de solution miracle là dessus ça dépend
vraiment des gens aussi parce que au
début quand j'essayais de faire des
titres comme ça il y en a j'ai eu
quelques retours de d'abonnés qui m'ont
dit j'ai failli me désabonner de taschen
j'ai cru que c'était michel cancer genre
ouais je ne vais pas citer mes jambes et
des chaînes horrible de désinformation
et tout or je joue là dessus mais c'est
vrai que au début quand on n'est pas
trop au courant ça peut surprendre mais
je pense que maintenant c'est bien
ancrée dans la tête du public
alors maintenant on va parler des choses
très importantes la thune donc quel est
mon modèle économique je suis sûr que
vous vous posez la question mon modèle
économique se constitue de toutes ces
choses là alors j'ai eu la chance de
décrocher une bourse du cnc talent l'an
dernier je crois
oui j'aime bien la légende de la photo
si vous la voyez
donc le service et a lancé le centre
national du cinéma et de l'image animée
donc c'est un organisme public qui
subventionne le cinéma est aussi je
crois qu'ils subventionnent des trucs à
la télé jean téléfilm aussi et
maintenant ils ont un fond pour les
youtuber qui est au cnc talent et donc
j'ai eu la chance de débourser enfin de
débourser nom de bourse est
un peu d'argent pour faire une série de
huit vidéos je crois avec eux donc
c'était hyper chouette
donc j'ai ça comme grosse source de
financement même si maintenant j'ai fini
les huit vidéos donc part je trouve que
je vous rassure j'ai refait une demande
de financement va voir si ça passe
j'ai aussi le financement participatif
de dons donc j'utilise jupe ip tipi
mais sa part s est plutôt anecdotique ça
doit être dans les 500 euros par mois à
peu près le cnc talent j'ai eu 25 mille
euros pour les polémiques vidéo sachant
que c'est pas 25000 euros dans ma poche
c'est pour la boîte de prod donc il y a
le matériel il ya le les salaires des
différents intervenants parce que si
j'ai besoin de quatre heures si j'ai
besoin d'eux alors monteur non c'est moi
qui fais mais bon j'ai utilisé des
recherchistes aussi pour un peu déblayé
le terrain où quelques sujets
donc l'argent entier ne va pas dans mes
poches un jeu
je ne dors pas dans une dans une
baignoire de billets mais mais c'était
quand même bien bien bien sympa de
pouvoir avoir ces points alors la pub
youtube tout le monde imagine que c'est
la source principale de revenus et que
ça rapporte énormément alors
pour ça peut-être vous surprendre mais
c'est absolument pas le cas et par
exemple le mois dernier j'ai gagné 30
dollars grâce à l appui bio tube donc je
remercie youtube et d'un mouvement de m
tellement tellement tellement devant nos
vidéos où on choisit même pas les pubs
en question et donc ça nous rapporte
très peu mais après c'est un bon
complément de salaire ça dépend aussi du
nombre de vues que vous faites ce genre
de choses ça dépend de beaucoup de
choses mais je sais même pas s'ils en
auront tous nos créateurs mais en tout
cas la plupart de gens disent que c'est
beaucoup moins que ce qu'on imagine
alors je faut que je remercie mon
financeur principal qui est pôle emploi
quand même presque
il faut savoir que c'est la plupart des
youtuber qui se lancent sont quand même
majoritairement au chômage en tout cas
au début donc je remercie pour la pop
qui m'ont bien aidé ça peut être le
sponsoring aussi ponctuellement que j'ai
fait un sponsoring pour l'instant je
peux pas révéler le montant mais pareil
c'est anecdotique
l'enseignement oui donc je fais d'autres
activités à côté donc ça peut être des
contrats des partenariats des piges des
trucs comme ça donc je fais des vidéos
pour d'autres gens ce genre de truc qui
ne se voit pas sur ma chaîne du coup
mais ça m'apporte de l'argent que je
peux après utilisé pour la chaîne et par
et j'enseigne aussi je vous évident
dans mon ancien master de journalisme
scientifique à paris diderot qui
dominèrent masters du monde et qui est
menacée derrière mais c'est un autre
sujet
donc voilà pour mes sources de revenus
et on va revenir un peu sur les
partenariats
ce match je pense à toi car ma dernière
vidéo j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir faire
une vidéo en partenariat avec le muséum
national d'histoire naturelle dans le
cadre de leurs programmes de sciences
participatives vigie terre autour des
cailloux donc si vous connaissez pas
visiteurs allaient voir parce que c'est
une terre bien mais bon je pense que
vous connaissez déjà vous public averti
et donc c'est le muséum qui m'a contacté
la semaine en particulier pour monter
une vidéo pour promouvoir ce
programme-là et expliquer un peu comment
se servaient de veigy terre tout ça
enfin comment le public pouvait
s'emparer de cet outil là et s'en servir
sur le terrain et donc voilà j'ai dit
banco allons-y et et ça c'est hyper bien
passée c'était une super super
expérience vraiment donc ça vraiment un
projet qu'on a monté ensemble à la fois
du point de vue éditorial détendu
pratique du point de vue de la
production de sa fin on a vraiment tous
ensemble donc c'était hyper chouette
c'est un vrai plaisir et puis c'est un
satellite en enrichissant parce qu'on
est arrivé à un point où un produit fini
qui est très différent de ce que
j'aurais pu faire tout seul ni même
imaginé tout seul et c'était vraiment
très chouette et donc dans la pratique
que je vous explique un peu ce qu'on a
fait des bouts on est allés visiter une
ancienne milice donc là pour le coup le
titre n'est pas tellement plus tactique
c'est vraiment ce qu'on est allé faire
une mine dans le canigou donc dans les
pyrénées orientales est une ancienne
mine pour aller voir différentes
affirmant sa et les répertorier sur le
site de veigy terre vous pour expliquer
un peu comment on répertoriait tout ça
et puis expliquer aussi bas tout le côté
historique de la mine et l'histoire des
mines
l'extraction minière du fer dans le
canigou qui est quand même un truc assez
important dans quoi et est donc voila
c'était hyper cool et ça nous a permis
aussi de montrer un peu le visage des
relais locaux du programme digital
jusque là du coup on était avec un
relais local du canigou qui est le
syndicat mixte du canigou grand sud
voilà asma n'hésite pas à me dire si
j'ai oublié des choses ou ou si j'ai dit
des bêtises c'est possible et donc la
vidéo c'est un espèce de vlog alors un
mélange de face caméra et de blogs qu'il
met sur place où j'étais avec des
copains vidéaste et eh ben on a exploré
les lieux on a regardé on a parlé
caillou il y avait aussi des experts
locaux du coup du syndicat mixte qui
nous ont expliqué l'histoire du lieu
l'histoire culturelle les stars
géologique et donc ça donne un objet un
peu particulier plein plein d'humour
comme jamais en tout cas et c'était cool
de pouvoir aller sur le terrain et ça
m'a beaucoup plu je vous invite à aller
voir cette vidéo
comme autre projet aussi de genre de
choses qui ne se voit pas sur ma chaîne
mais qui se risquent de tout que je fais
j'ai participé à deux et bientôt trois
saisons du vortex donc le vortex c'est
une chaîne de vulgarisation collective
donc en fait ils simulent un
dépend si je suis trop longues parce que
je surveille absolument pas le temps qui
simule une colocation entre début de la
crise à tort et la colocation change à
chaque saison donc là on m'a filmé la
sixième saison il ya deux semaines je
pense comme ça et donc c'était hyper
cool j'ai eu l'immense honneur de faire
partie de trois saisons il coupe la
dernière qu'on a tourné mais qui n'est
pas encore diffusée et c'était hyper
chouette donc j'ai fait une vidéo pas
uniquement de géologie d'ailleurs mais
j'ai parlé du sel on peut voir du sel
donc c'est plus biologie là pour le coup
c'est les adaptations de la faune et de
la flore à
au milieu hyper ça j'ai fait un truc un
peu plus axé philo il se pare des
sciences sur la hiérarchie des sciences
selon auguste comte
voilà l'histoire de deux tailles et un
peu la pédologie par rapport aux autres
domaines de la géologie pardon pardon
les paix de l'onu
et donc avant j'avais fait une vidéo
aussi sur la fossilisation une autre sur
les météorites
grâce à vichy ciel aussi bisous asma tué
par tous et une vidéo aussi sur le rire
du point de vue de la psychologie
évolutionnaire en gros pourquoi le rire
du point de vue de l'évolution
voilà donc c'est hyper choix tu es tu
[Musique]
cheveux aussi d'autres trucs par
ailleurs donc ça aussi c'est des choses
qui ne se voit pas sur ma chaîne céder
une nouvelle collaboration je veux
passer vite en a presque fini sa
nouvelle collaboration sur la chaîne
info ou mytho qui est lancée par milan
presse donc ces géo ado tous ces trucs
là
je veux qu'il ya d'autres enfin c'est
surtout géo ado
donc des petites vidéos sur sur les
théories du complot pour expliquer les
théories du complot voilà j'en ai fait
une la première sur le les illuminati de
bavière ce qui était fait que ma tenue
voilà donc je fais plein de choses
autour de la chaîne et c'est ça qui est
bien c'est que en fait la chaîne ça
donne une vitrine pour faire plein
d'autres trucs autour et c'est hyper
choc voilà les projets à venir alors je
suis produite par la sq et une boîte qui
est
qui produit j'ai envie de dire la moitié
des vulgarisateurs
sur youtube à l'heure actuelle nota bene
la moustiquaire
copains du web enfin il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de monde monsieur fille aussi
et donc j'ai hâte de pouvoir faire plein
de choses avec eux parce que ils savent
y faire et d'ailleurs ma dernière vidéo
avec le muséum et est produite par
naissent déjà
beaucoup à faire plein de choses
ensemble et puis j'aimerais bien les moi
même plus sur le terrain d'ailleurs la
demande de subvention que j'ai fait au
cnc dernièrement sa s'orientent plutôt
là dessus donc voilà faire d'autres
vidéos sur le terrain un peu comme
justement pour visiteurs donc si jamais
vous avez des opportunités si vous avez
des idées si vous avez si vous avez
l'occasion de m'accueillir chez vous
dans mon labo sur le terrain tout ça de
faire le guide je suis tout à fait
ouverte à toute collaboration voilà
bah voila je crois que ça s'arrête là
donc merci de votre attention
[Musique]